vous êtes sur public sénat bonjour à
tous ce qu'est ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
dans la gestion de la crise sanitaire
qu'est ce qui peut être doit être même
améliorée notamment au niveau
administratif c'est l'objet de la
commission d'enquêté mise en place cet
été par le sénat cet après midi ce sont
les syndicats d' internes des hôpitaux
qui sont entendues hors garde l'audition
ne repasse juste après on qui ont fait 6
ans de médecine et qui sont désormais à
temps plein à l'hôpital pour prendre en
charge les patients jusqu'à la fin de
leur internat et l'obtention de leur
diplôme d'enseignement supérieur pendant
pendant cette crise pendant cette crise
sanitaire les internes ont été ont été
en première ligne
ils représentent 25 % des médecins
hospitaliers et 40 % des médecins dans
les chu est habituellement les internes
sont indispensables au fonctionnement
des hôpitaux
c'est important pour moi de revenir sur
le contexte dans lequel cette crise
sanitaire est arrivé quand quand a
commencé là que la crise sanitaire nous
avons mis fin le 19 février une grève
historique qui a duré 70 jours dans
laquelle nous nous sommes fortement
mobilisés contre les manques de moyens
et de personnel je tiens à signaler que
pendant ces soixante dix jours de grève
qui a été massivement suivi aucune de
nos revendications notamment sur les
questions du temps de travail et des
situations d'épuisement professionnel
que nous avons que nous avons fait
remonter ont été entendus nous avons
fait en 2019 une enquête qui a retrouvé
un temps hebdomadairement et moyens de
travail qui était de l'ordre de 56
heures
est ce que nous demandons c'est que la
réglementation française permettent un
décompte horaire du temps de travail des
internes pour ne plus dépasser la
réglementation européenne qui est de
l'ordre de 48 heures là dessus nous
avons eu un refus à l'époque de madame
la ministre
agnès buzyn début depuis début 2000
vingt quand a commencé la crise
sanitaire
il y avait déjà quatre internes qui
s'était suicidé notamment à cause
d'épuisement professionnel
je vous passe les chiffres sur le sur le
sur la santé mentale des internes en
france mais elle est catastrophique et
les situations d'épuisement sont
nombreuses
c'est donc dans ce contexte qui est
arrivée la crise sanitaire
est ce que je dois ce que je dois dire
tout d'abord c'est que dans nos rapports
avec les instances nationales qui sont
d'habitude assez d'assez bonne qualité
avec des réunions bi hebdomadaire nous
discutons avec les conseillers des
cabinets notre interlocuteur est le
directeur de cabinet et bien là il ya eu
un retard à l'allumage puisque nous
avons écrit un courrier le 19 février
pour être reçu par les cabinets et ce
n'est que le 19 mars que nous avons
enfin eu une réponse et une proposition
de rendez vous donc c'est passé un mois
un mois de latence pendant lesquels nous
n'avons eu ni consigne ni initiative des
différentes administrations pour nous
permettre notamment de réaffecter les
internes là où il ya là où il y en avait
besoin
nous avons donc décidé de prendre
l'initiative de ces réaffectations afin
de placer les internes
des services qui étaient les moins
surchargées dans les services où il y
avait besoin d'eux c'est à dire les
recenser faire état de leurs compétences
pour pouvoir les replacer nous avons
aussi réalisé un appel à la mobilisation
générale des internes pour faire revenir
tous ceux qui étaient en vacances en
disponibilité en année recherche et
qu'ils puissent prendre leurs fonctions
je veux dire que là dedans les
administrations étaient particulièrement
absente
nous avons dû créer nos propres cellules
de crise pour l'organiser comme la
cellule de crise de de l'île de france
dont julien pour parler plus amplement
pour organiser toutes ces réaffectations
l'important pour nous était avant tout
qu'il n'y ait pas pendant cette crise
sanitaire de suicide d'un interne par
épuisement professionnel
nous avons érigé le droit au
remplacement permettre à l'internaute
d'être remplacé par un collègue quand il
sentait que la charge de travail était
trop importante
nous avons nous avons fini par écrire un
courrier cosigné par la conférence des
doyens de santé la conférence des dg de
chu la conférence des présidents de cme
pour obtenir des mesures réglementaires
qui était qui était nécessaire pour
pouvoir procéder à ces réaffectations
plusieurs mesures étaient nécessaires et
ce n'est qu'à la suite de ce courrier
que nous avons finalement obtenu une
instruction des cabinets puis de des
rendez vous avec hebdomadaire avec les
cabinets permettant de faire d'appliquer
au mieux la réglementation et de mettre
en place des guides à destination des rs
et des centres hospitaliers pour
améliorer les conditions
parmi ces mesures une mesure qui a été
pour nous très importante
ça a été de repousser la fin de semestre
moment les internautes à terminent tous
au 1er mai et il était clair que dans le
contexte actuel on ne pouvait pas
désorganiser l'ensemble des services et
se priver d'une bonne partie des
internes actuellement en fonction
nous avons donc demandé à ce que la fin
de semaine sera repoussée d'un mois ce
qui a permis aussi de conserver des
médecins au sein de l'hôpital public
parmi parmi les faits qui ont été qui
ont été marquants nous avons réalisé
plusieurs plusieurs enquêtes et je dois
dire que les conclusions que qu'on en a
tiré son sont graves
c'est à dire que sur notre enquête nous
avons interrogé 981 terme
les deux tiers d'entre nous disent ne
pas avoir pu accéder à du matériel de
protection en quantité suffisante
on parle là de deux masques de sur blues
on a eu que la moitié des internes 53%
qui présentaient des symptômes ducobu
début de la crise qui ont pu accéder à
des tests de dépistage
c'est à dire que la plupart des internes
n'ont pas pu connaître leur statut et on
sait aujourd'hui que plus d'un interne
sur deux qui connaissait son diagnostic
étant positive au co vide a été obligé
de travailler malgré sa positivité
donc c'est à dire qu'il a mis en danger
des collègues à lui et qu'il a aussi
bien entendu mis en danger des patients
nous savons que les soignants et
particulièrement les internes sont une
source de contamination pour les
patients pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont dû
travailler parce que les politiques de
gestion des ressources humaines des
hôpitaux notamment à destination des
internes sont de très mauvaise qualité
la durée moyenne des arrêts maladie a
été de 8 jours il ya eu aucun contrôle
aucune surveillance et surtout le
personnel étaient manquants on ne
pouvait pas dans les services se mettre
en arrêt maladie et arrêter de soigner
les patients
je tiens à rajouter que 5% des internes
infectées ont présenté une forme sévère
de la maladie
heureusement nous n'avons pas eu à
déplorer la perte d'un interne mais un
certain nombre a été hospitalisé pour
cette maladie
je tiens aussi à souligner qu'il n'ya
pas eu de priorisation pour le
rapatriement
des personnels soignants et des internes
à l'étranger et qu'on nous a renvoyé
vers le ministère des affaires
étrangères sans aucune sans aucune aide
pour rapatrier des forces sur le
territoire je pense que les dix minutes
sont sont assez je l'attends relève
merci beaucoup
alors monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les rapporteurs et mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et du coup je
m'appelle je lui en folio je suis
président du syndicat des internes des
hôpitaux paris et je représente les
internes de l'interrégion ile de france
qui est une région assez dense en ce qui
concerne les internes puisqu'un interne
sur six en france est affecté en
ile-de-france à l'ap-hp on est six mille
interne en ile-de-france comme tu le
disais juste un dès le 16 mars en fait à
l'instar de nos collègues interne de la
région grand est
on a proposé à la ronge l agence
régionale de santé de s'organiser
nous-mêmes pour récolter toutes les tous
les noms des internes ou volontaires
pourraient les aider dans les services
qui étaient en difficulté
on a eu des réponses d'abord de la
conférence des doyens d'île de france
puis de la rsl l'ap-hp donc on a dû se
mettre en accord avec leur plan
organisationnel qui nous imposait de
déclarer chaque interne qui changeait
d'hôpital ou de service à son
coordonnateur donc qui est le
responsable de son diplôme mais
également à son doyen à son chef de
service à la rs est ainsi qu à l ap hp
qui est son chu de rattachement et
également pour la gestion du coût de ces
internes
on a recruté 31 interne qui était dédiée
à temps plein à la gestion également des
retours des services qui avait besoin de
médecins c'est principalement grâce à
des situations particulières qu'on
aurait pu recruter des internes qui
pouvaient travailler à temps plein sur
cette problématique parce que c'était
principalement des internes qui étaient
en situation de grossesse donc qui
devait être en éviction des services ou
bien également des internes qui avaient
qui ont des pathologies chroniques et
qui devait également être en éviction
donc c'est 31 internes ont pu rassembler
un réseau de 250 interne à travers les
hôpitaux d'île de france où on avait
chaque on avait des données quotidiennes
sur la situation tendue en médecins et
en interne de chaque service de
réanimation d'urgence et
d'hospitalisation covit d'île de france
chaque jour une remontée le besoin de
médecins ce qu'on a pu faire du coup
c'est récolter les données et les noms
et les contacts des internes qui étaient
volontaires pour participer à l'offre de
soins et au soutien à ces services qui
étaient en difficulté dès le 16 mars
on a lancé un questionnaire en ligne
pour récolter les le nom des internes ou
volontaire en tout sur deux mois on a pu
récolter 1900 interne franciliens qui
souhaitait aider les internautes
enfin qu'il souhaitait aider les
services en difficultés dont 1200 dans
les 48 premières heures et nous avons pu
participer à près de 600 transfert
dans les services en difficultés en ile
de france à côté de ça comme comme tu
disais juste un on a également eu besoin
de soutenir les internes qui était en
difficulté parce que notre syndicat
une cellule spécifique de soutien
psychique et morale parce que les
internes en des risques psychosociaux
bien spécifiques comme comme tu le
disais précédemment on l'intersyndicale
nationale des internes avaient déjà pu
faire des des enquêtes sur la santé
mentale des internes qui relevait déjà
deux tiers 2 internes qui ont des
symptômes anxieux
un tiers des symptômes dépressifs et un
choeur qui ont des idées suicidaires
dans le dernier mois
lisse ni a également pu faire une
enquête santé mentale suite à la crise
qu vide et tous ces chiffres ont été
revus à la hausse et donc on sait
organiser nous-mêmes pour avoir pour
augmenter en tout cas notre ambras notre
cellule de soutien psychologique au sein
du syndicat des internes des hôpitaux de
paris
en ce qui concerne également la gestion
des internes du coup à travers l'île de
france et que on est répartie
habituellement dans près de 180 hôpitaux
partout en ile-de-france ce soit dans
l'intra muros ou dans les départements
de la grande couronne et notre but
vraiment c'était de répartir les
internes dans tous les hôpitaux y
compris les hôpitaux qui sont déjà en
difficulté habituellement je pense par
exemple à l'hôpital de longjumeau qui
est déjà en difficulté habituellement
qui en manque de médecins notre volonté
c'était vraiment de répartir l'offre de
soins sur l'ensemble des territoires
français
on a dû du coup accompagner les internes
qui était en difficulté ne serait ce que
pour se loger à proximité ces hôpitaux
ou de se déplacer dans ces hôpitaux
parce que quand on sort d'une guerre de
réanimation ou une garde aux urgences ou
d'une journée qui traîne et on termine à
21h à meaux c'est difficile de rentrer
quand les transports en commun sont
réduits du fait de la crise sanitaire
du coup on s'est arrangé également avec
cette île de crise pour obtenir des
logements et des facilités de transport
pour l'ensemble des internes qui étaient
affectés dans des hôpitaux périphériques
avec un grand soutien de la région ile
de france qui nous a également aidés
avec une conciergerie entièrement
gratuite pour les internes francilien
avec des voitures mises à disposition et
des logements y compris des logements
crous voilà merci beaucoup merci à vous
même de roche notre rapporte heureux
c'est un tous les deux de des précisions
vous nous donner sur le rôle et la
situation des internes au monde au
moment de la crise lorsque vous évoquez
solution un peu d'organisation qui vous
a été propre pour pour mettre en place
ce réseau des internes
quel a été le soutien vous avez parlé de
la région ile-de-france qui vous
apporter un soutien quel a été le
soutien la rs dans cette gestion le
deuxième point c'est vous décrivez une
situation de difficulté psychologique
des internes même parfois même avant la
dcri chez les étudiants en santé
est ce que cette gestion de crise au
moment de la première vague a accentué
ses difficultés si vous avez des d
analyse comment comment vous êtes
soutenus sur ce plan là et par rapport à
la situation des internes qui sont en
formation puisque vous avez des défaites
des études en même temps qu'eux enfin
des études dans le cadre de cette
fonction d'un thème quel est l'impact
sur des études dans des spécialités par
exemple que vous notez par rapport à des
des internes qui on est obligé de enfin
qu'ils ont été contraints de rester sur
sur des services qu'ovide par rapport
aux stages qu'il devait faire dans
d'autres services assez pour cette
première partie est ma deuxième question
elle porte sur la situation actuelle
comment vous voyez dans l'est
les services sur lesquels vous êtes
vous-même ou vos collègues comment ça se
passe que la situation actuelle
puisqu'on en est maintenant à un stade
de couvre feu pour pouvoir essayer
d'enrayer la d'enrayer le nombre
d'hospitalisations essentiellement dans
des services qui sont tendues enfin qui
risquent de l'être et surtout des
services avec aussi des lits qui sont
opérationnels manque de personnel quel
est votre avis sur cette mesure
merci merveilleux merci monsieur le
président alors n'étant pas médecin
bon je vous entends avec beaucoup
d'attention et je suis assez effaré de
vous entendre
bien sûr nous avons procédé à beaucoup
d'auditions a déjà avec cette commission
denquête mais un moment donné on nous a
dit que les freins administratifs et
financiers avaient été levées et que par
exemple on avait pu ouvrir des unités
des lits de réanimation en trois jours
alors pourquoi est-ce que c'est aussi
compliqué de déplacer des internes d'un
service à un autre ça c'est quelque
chose qui m'épate
on a bien entendu des praticiens nous
dira qu' il y avait plus de frein à un
moment donné on sait que financièrement
effectivement il y en avait plus et sans
doute administrativement non plus
puisque quand il faut ouvrir des unités
il faut parfois trois ans pour arriver à
le faire et là en trois jours on pouvait
le faire mais mais ce qu'on pouvait
faire en trois jours sur des aspects
techniques des aspects d'équipement au
niveau des ressources humaines on
pouvait toujours pas le faire est ce que
c'est ça que vous nous expliquer
déplacés internes d'un service à un
autre vous pouvez toujours pas le faire
on la crise grecque vous me confirmer
cet aspect et est donc en quelque sorte
que n'a pas fait la rs et
particulièrement en ile de france parce
que au travers de nos éditions
on a carrément eu l'impression que s'il
ya un endroit où ça s'était bien passé
entre les élus l'état et puis
et puis eux
les praticiens c'est en ile de france
alors voilà je voudrais des précisions
sur sur ces aspects là et est-ce que du
coup c'est ces complications au niveau
des ressources humaines
ce que vous pouvez nous dire si ça ne
concerne que les internes ou si ça a
concerné tout le personnel merci je vous
laisse répondre à toutes ces questions
dans la mesure des bouts de vos
possibilités
je vais essayer de répondre au mieux si
j'ai si jamais j'ai oublié quelques
questions n'hésitez pas
n'hésitez pas à me redire puisque je
commence par votre question parce que
c'est la plus fraîche
en interne il a affecté dans un service
réglementairement pour qu'ils changent
de service jusque là c'était c'était pas
possible dans la réglementation faut
bien voir cam interne c'est un médecin
prescripteur et cantiques anti prescrit
c'est par délégation du chef de service
de son chef de service quand il prescrit
il met sa responsabilité pénale en jeu
et il peut être accusé pénalement
d'homicide involontaire déjà eu
plusieurs cas donc nous on avait besoin
d'un support réglementaire pour faire
cesser réaffectation or ce que ce que
j'expliquais ci qui a eu il ya eu un
délai vraiment une sorte de sidération
pendant laquelle on n'a pas pu obtenir
ce support réglementaire on la demandait
tôt on l'a obtenu le 18 mars
donc c'est à dire que jusqu'au 18 mars
on a fait des réaffectations mais on
mettait en danger la responsabilité
pénale de nos mandants donc ça c'était
ça c'était la première raison la
deuxième j'ai peut-être plus laisser
julien en parler pour pour la pratique
de la mise en place d'une réaffectation
comment ça se passe et comment ça se
passe avec les interlocuteurs pour l'île
de france
et puis j'apporterai peut-être des
compléments de réponse pour les autres
pour les autres régions
en ce qui concerne le plus nos relations
avec les intitulés les institutions que
se soit l'agencé régionale de santé ou
ou l'ap-hp keynote chu de rattachement
ça a été également ça ça a été un peu on
a envoyé une solution clé en main
vraiment à l'agencé régionale de santé
parce que ce qui est vraiment difficile
c'est qu'en fait on avait besoin de
compétences dans les services sauf que
les institutions entre ont beaucoup de
mal à connaître quel médecin qu'elle
interne à quelles compétences alors oui
il ya les internes
d'anesthésie-réanimation et les internes
d'un intensiviste qui eux c'est écrit
dans leur diplôme s'affairent des
réanimations auraient été tous les
autres un internaute cardiologie ça
passe en réanimation à l'interné pato
qu'être entérologie ça passe en
réanimation ça c'est aussi faire de la
réanimation où il faut qu'il soit
encadré mais sa vie mais il sait en
faire et ça que ce soit le chu que ce
soit les coordonnateurs où que ce soit
la rsl ils ne savent pas qui sont ces
internats également les certaine qu'ils
passent aux urgences la majorité de
l'immense majorité des spécialités passe
aux urgences et faits des gardes aux
urgences la rs ne sait pas qui sont ces
internes qui ont des capacités de
pouvoir gérer des urgences nous du coup
qui enfin qui sait de mieux que quelques
compétences sur les internes cd interne
m
et donc on a demandé aux internes qui
avaient des compétences de réanimation
qui avaient des compétences d'urgence et
on les a dispatché grâce à ça c'était
pas compliqué du tout de pouvoir changer
des internes de services dans les
hôpitaux
parce que comme tu le disais en fait un
interne c'est financé par l'agencé
régionale de santé
il ya des sous qui sont donnés à
l'hôpital tous les mois pour qu'ils
payent leur interne en fonction de la
répartition dans les différents services
et de l'ancienneté
ce qui posait un truc non pas de
problème s'était changée en interne de
service quand c'était dans le même
hôpital
parce qu'en fait c'est le même hôpital
qui payent ce qui a été très compliqué
c'était de changer
l'internaute d'hôpital donc on a dû
mettre en place un système de validation
avec les directions des affaires
médicales des hôpitaux
les coordonnateurs l'agencé régionale de
santé mais tous ces gens d'avoir et
boucle pour chaque interne qui changeait
d'hôpital donc vous imaginez qu'ils
étaient relativement dense pendant un
certain moment et en fait qui a créé le
plus de problème à mon sens c'est que la
dg os a mis en place des faq pour aider
au mieux les acteurs du terrain dans la
gestion des étudiants en santé et des
internes ce qui a été le plus
problématique à mon sens oui pardon ce
qui est ce qui a créé le plus de
problèmes administrativement c'est qu'en
fait elle ne tranchait pas sûr qu'ils
devaient payer un intérêt
en interne il est affecté dans un
hôpital pour six mois habituellement
donc l'hôpital dans lequel il est
affecté reçoit des sous pendant six mois
pour le rémunérer sont internes sauf que
là on devait le changer d'hôpital au
milieu sauf qu'en fait son ancien
hôpital continuer à toucher les sous et
le nouvel hôpital dans lequel ils
étaient réaffectées ne touchez pas de
sous pour le payer et moi je me suis
retrouvé en situation en gestion
vraiment où aucun des deux hôpitaux ne
voulait payer l'internaute parce que il
n'est plus chez moi
oui mais il vient pas de chez moi là
jusqu'au mois d'août que j'ai géré avec
les directions des affaires médicales de
tous les hôpitaux d'ile-de-france des
internes qui n'ont pas été payés pendant
deux mois
donc là et ces internats ils me l'ont
déjà dit ils me l'ont dit d'office s'il
ya une deuxième vague je ne viendrai pas
aidé parce que je n'ai pas été payé par
rapport aux questions du coup que vous
avez pu soulever de santé mentale du
coup le il y avait déjà des risques
psychosociaux vraiment très particulier
sur les internés à une psychopathologie
déjà de fonds relativement importante et
en fait les enquêtes qui a été fait
suite à la crise qu bid a montré qu'il y
avait eu une aggravation de l'ensemble
des symptômes que ce soit d'anxiété ou
de dépression mais également avec
accompagné tine de symptomatologie
traumatique et nos structures de soutien
en fait psychique et moral aux internes
bon on avait triplé les effectifs pour
qu' il puisse les soutenir et également
à ce qu'on puisse les réorienter parce
que du coup ils ont besoin d'être
orienté soit auprès de psychiatre auprès
des psychologues
les internes qui ont téléphoné ne serait
ce que pour avoir un soutien psy chic is
a également explosé
on avait vraiment besoin de monde
l'impact sur la formation du coût de
cette crise sanitaire pour les médecins
ça a été multiples là vous avez pu en
parler beaucoup hier lors de la
commission de avec les investisseurs et
animateur c'est qu'en fait les blocs
chirurgicaux ont été fermés toutes les
opérations non urgentes ont été annulés
bah oui mais sauf que l'on a des
internes des chirurgies informés et eux
ont été envoyés dans les réanimations
pour retourner les malades et faire ce
qu'il pouvait dans les services de
médecine ou d'urgence et donc du coup en
fait on arrive là avec des centaines de
chirurgie qui sont moins bien formés
parce qu'ils n'ont pas fait le bloc
pendant trois quatre cinq mois souvent
pour des du coup en ile-de-france avec
des terrains de stage de très
spécifiques et ultraspécialisés pour
lequel même des internes d'autres
régions viennent pour se former
du coup là il ya un manque de formation
pendant plusieurs mois
et également du coup les internes qui se
formaient à la recherche parce que du
coup on avait énormément en interne qui
était en laboratoire à tous les
laboratoires ont été fermés donc bon moi
ma situation particulière c'est que
j'étais en laboratoire mais des analyses
statistiques dont je pouvais faire ça
depuis chez moi mais par contre pour
tous les internes qui était en
laboratoire de recherche et qu'il devait
manipuler toit était fermé
donc beaucoup d'intérêt n'ont pas été
formés à la recherche comme il l'était
habituellement pas avant si je peux je
suis un peut compléter les ce que ce que
ce que julien dit sur la partie sur la
partie financement des internes
il ya la moitié du financement des
postes d'un terne qui sont versées par
les ars sur ce qu'on appelle les
enveloppes mairie qui sont d une sous
enveloppe de l'ondam et l'autre moitié
qui est financé par l'hôpital lui-même
c'est-à-dire globalement sur de là sur
la t2a sur la tarification à l'activité
c'est cette partie je pense t2a qui a
entraîné ces conflits entre les
différents hôpitaux et le fait que le
ministère de la santé
malgré nos demandes répétées émis un tel
temps à trancher sur qui devait être le
payeur non voulais que ce soit
l'établissement d'origine qu'ils soient
meilleurs dans tous les cas mais on voit
que les vieilles logiques budgétaire
tout simplement on continue et on
continuer à fonctionner ce qu'on a ce
qu'on a milité pendant le ségur de la
santé ce qu'on a obtenu sur un
engagement d'accord c'est que les
internes ne soient plus payés par de la
t2a mais uniquement sur des enveloppes
mairie en disant bien que la formation
des médecins ne doit pas passer sur de
la tarification à l'activité en gros de
la rentabilité qui permet de payer la
formation des médecins que ça n'avait
aucun sens maintenant on espère que ces
travaux iront le plus vite possible
parce que c'est juste un engagement de
commencer ses travaux il n'y a pas deux
il n'y a pas de délais qui sont qui sont
mentionnés là dedans sur la partie sur
le sur le l'asb et l'aspect
psychologique ce qui ce qui est
important de comprendre aussi c'est que
les internes c'est vraiment des gens qui
sont globalement
leur priorité c'est leur formation ils
sont très dévoués aux soins du patient
est en fait on a eu beaucoup de
témoignages d'un terne qui nous faisait
part de situations d'anxiété mais pas
tant au final la peur de la maladie ou
de ne pas savoir prendre en charge les
patients mais surtout la peur de se
retrouver dans une situation où vous
êtes aux urgences un service que vous ne
connaissez pas vous n'avez pas accès à
du matériel de protection
vous avez peur de vous contaminer 2
contaminent les autres de contaminer
votre famille quand vous rentrez donc
c'est un sentiment à la fois de peur et
de colère entremêlées et eva est
vraiment la détresse psychologique qui
en est né et ai été intense et on a
vraiment des situations de stress post
traumatique qui conte était qu'on était
fréquemment retrouvées sur la partie de
là sur la partie de la formation
je pense que tous les internes toute la
formation enfin la formation tous les
internes a été impactée dans cette
période qu vite parce que tout le monde
s'est retrouvé déplacer en quelque sorte
à faire une autre tâche qui n'est pas
celle pour lequel il est en train de se
former et plus spécifiquement sur sur la
partie de la formation des internes à la
prise en charge du co vide on a 46 % des
internes qui ont déclaré avoir une
mauvaise formation à la prévention du
risque de contamination et à la prise en
charge des patients pendant la crise
qu'ovide 60% des internes se sont formés
eux mêmes
et non pas eu de petites formations
dispensées par leur établissement
nous on a mis en place une plate forme
de formation numérique pour pallier à ce
manque
mais voilà la qualité aussi de la
formation en temps de crise n'a pas été
au rendez vous merci je vais passer la
parole à madame cohen
merci monsieur le président et merci
messieurs pour pour vous vous éléments
dans le débat qui sont extrêmement
instructif et en même temps effrayant
parce que vous vous dites les choses
avec beaucoup de sincérité et sans
détour et c'est important pour notre
notre commission notre commission
denquête moi j'ai trois questions à vous
poser de manière plus précise continue
donc de ce que vous nous avez décrit
comme conditions d'exercice de votre
activité extrêmement extrêmement
difficile est-ce que vous avez
aujourd'hui à votre connaissance le fait
que des internes aurait ou a abandonné
finalement le métier pour lequel il
s'était destinée
parce que ça peut aussi avoir
malheureusement assez conséquent cela
donc est-ce que vous avez des éléments
là dessus ma deuxième ma deuxième
question c'est que il est quand même
beaucoup question d'un manque de deux
médecins il ya un numerus clausus qui
est censé avoir été abandonné mais on
sait pertinemment qu'il ne l'est pas
puisque il n'y a pas plus de moyens qui
sont donnés à l'université pour former
plus de médecins donc voilà c'est
simplement enfin pour moi le ministère
qui s'est défaussé mais il n'y a pas
d'actes concrets et comment vous évaluez
finalement ce qu'il faudrait faire pour
effectivement avoir plus de médecins
formés 3e troisième question c'est
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
dans la gestion de la crise avec donc là
cette deuxième vague je pas si on peut
dire deuxième vague d'ailleurs mais
enfin je veux dire deuxième vague qui
arrive est ce que vous avez le sentiment
des lieux
ont été tirées et notamment par rapport
justement à la façon dont on a maltraité
les internes
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'il
y à une amélioration que des leçons ont
été tirées et que vous avez été quelques
peu entendu et une question subsidiaire
je suis pas sûr d'avoir bien bien
entendu pardonnez moi de vous faire
répéter pendant là pendant la pandémie
donc au printemps vous vous avez au
combien d'heures en moyenne finalement
vous avez travaillé sachant que il me
semble que la durée légale ces 48 heures
donc je pense que vous avez largement
dépassé cette durée mais bon voilà
est-ce que je peux avoir des éléments et
pardonnez moi de vous faire peut-être
répéter je vous laisse répondre à toutes
celles ci merci merci pour ces questions
alors sur sur le fait que le
découragement ou le décrochage en tout
cas des internes en médecine
là dessus on a malheureusement pas de
données on a connaissance de cas
individuels de personnes qui ont arrêté
leurs études
particulièrement après après après ce
qui s'est passé pendant la crise qu vide
je pense que inde et des premiers
facteurs malheureusement ça a été un
facteur financier parce que comme les 10
juin il ya certains internes qui n'ont
pas été payés pendant cet épisode de
crise déjà par le passé il faut savoir
que
la question financière est quand même et
quand même un frein et entraîne un
décrochage d'un certain nombre d'
interne en interne
en moyenne c'est payé 1800 euros nets et
ben à paris il ya un certain nombre
d'entre eux qui quand on a 25 ans une
famille arrive pas assurent avec un avec
un tel salaire et préfère prendre un
boulot d'infirmiers et d'aides-soignants
ou carrément de changer de voie moi ça a
été encore plus plus compliqué et
surtout je pense qu'il ya un sentiment
qui a été très important ça a été celui
de se dire que les internes était
dangereux pour leurs familles vous allez
travailler
moi j'ai eu j'ai eu des cas on a
rapporté des gens qui ne rentraient plus
chez eux
allez à l'hôtel par peur de contaminer
de contaminer leurs familles et ça ça
fait partie des choses qui bien entendu
vous des motifs de cette de cette
formation
alors malheureusement on a très peu de
données sur sur le décrochage le l'ordre
national des médecins avaient avait
sorti la statistique de 20% des
étudiants qui décrocherait entre le
début de leurs études et la fin mais
malheureusement actuellement il n'ya il
n'ya pas de suivi des étudiants en
médecine entre la première et la
dernière année il n'y a pas de
statistiques on est incapable de nous
dire combien il ya de suicides combien
il ya d'arrêt maladie
ceci n'est pas étudiée donc certes il ya
une pénurie de médecins mais si on ne
connaît pas les statistiques déjà du
décrochage et des causes du décrochage
on ne pourra pas résoudre cette question
alors après il ya deux façons de faire
ce soit c'est un verre qui se remplit et
malheureusement qui fuit donc on a deux
solutions soit son boucher la fuite soit
on augmente le remplissage pour ce qui
est des fuites bas tant qu'on a pas ces
statistiques malheureusement ne pourra
rien faire pour ce qui est d'augmenter
le remplissage comme vous l'avait bien
dit les capacités de formation
ils sont actuellement quand même
largement saturé c'est un sentiment
qu'on ressent dans quasiment toutes les
subdivisions et dans quasiment toutes
les spécialités notamment les
spécialités d'anesthésie-réanimation on
voit pas vraiment comment
est ce qu'on sera en capacité de former
de former plus d'un terme
alors il ya bien des il ya bien des
pistes qui sont évoqués mais comme vous
l'avez évoqué nécessairement ça demande
plus de moyens universitaire que ce
qu'on a actuellement vous avez vous
aviez posé une dernière question excusez
moi je crois que j'ai à hurler sur les
heures de travail je suis je suis désolé
nous n'avons pas nous n'avons pas compté
les heures de travail pendant cette
période qu vite je pense que ça a été ça
a été bien supérieur d'un autre côté il
ya aussi certains internes dans
certaines spécialités qui se sont
retrouvés complètement à l'arrêt et sans
la capacité d'aider d'autres personnes
je ne peux pas donner je peux pas donner
de chiffres précis ce qu'on sait c'est
que voilà en 2019 on a fait une offre on
a refait notre étude sur le temps de
travail
on n'a retrouvé que 56 étaient 56 heures
hebdomadaires en moyenne que 10 % des
internes font plus de 79 heures par
semaine particulièrement des internes de
chirurgie que le repos de sécurité et de
moins en moins respectée et un tiers des
internes qui dit ne pas prendre sans
repos de sécurité donc après une garde
de 24 heures systématiquement sur cette
donnée là ça s'aggrave par rapport à
en 2012 on avait déjà fait une enquête
qui a retrouvé un temps de travail est
exorbitant qui avait entraîné par la
commission européenne une auto saisie
qui avait demandé à modifier le décret
sur le temps de travail
le décret avait été modifié sauf que le
problème c'est qu'actuellement le décret
qui est qui qui est en cours pour nous
il est très problématique parce que
notre temps de travail il n'est pas
défini comme d'autres en heure ou ou en
quoi que ce soit il est défini en demi
journée et quand je vais travailler la
nuit pendant 14 heures d'affilée ça va
me décompter deux demi journées
donc vous comprenez que partant de là
notre temps de travail
il peut pas être il peut pas être
correct la demi-journée elle n'est pas
définie elle n'est pas borné
et en pratique personne n'arrive à faire
respecter ce texte et on a beau parler
derrière le ministre maintient qu'il va
y avoir des sanctions sur les hôpitaux
qui ne respectent pas le texte
on dit que ce texte il c'est pas
possible de c'est pas possible de le
mettre en application un système qui va
juste compter des demi journées et qui
pour une nuit vous compte deux demi
journées ça ne permettra jamais
d'atteindre des conditions de travail
satisfaisantes
on demande ce qu'on demande en fait
c'est beaucoup plus de contrôle beaucoup
plus de deux forces des ressources
humaines est hélas a rejoint un peu
votre question madame vermeille et c'est
les ressources humaines hospitalière
elle aussi son déficit de personnel et
n'arrivent pas à assurer leurs fonctions
il ya une fonction essentielle des
ressources humaines qui est celle de la
prévention des risques psychosociaux et
notamment du décompte horaire du temps
de travail et ça c'est absolument pas
fait nulle part et pour les internes
encore moins que pour le reste des des
praticiens de l'hôpital et c'est ce qui
fait aussi que derrière ces services de
ressources humaines quand il se retrouve
face à une crise sanitaire ne sont pas
en capacité de les gérer merci monsieur
roger karoutchi
pardon monsieur le président mais est ce
que mes sentiments
c'est une question c'est est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment que cette deuxième
vague
pour cette deuxième vague il ya eu une
prise en compte de vos aux
avertissements de vos analyses et que ça
tient devant être mieux
c'est très très très honnêtement non
j'étais absolument aucun espoir là
dessus d'autant plus d'autant plus à la
lecture des résultats du secteur de la
santé puis dire le secteur de la santé
on a obtenu et on a dû se battre pour ça
d'arrivée est payé au smic horaire
voilà ce qu'on a obtenu ce sur le temps
de travail
il ya eu aucune écoute non non j'ai
complètement pessimiste et là où par
contre nous on a un retour d'expérience
c'est que comme le dit julien énormément
d'un terne sont épuisés et ils ont
compris que eux mêmes en fait s'il
allait se porter volontaire s'il allait
aider dans les services se mettait en
danger ils le feront plus monsieur
karoutchi
bon
sincèrement j'espère qu'on n'aura pas le
coït
parce que s'il faut aller l'hôpital je
serai pas rassuré comme disent qu'il
faut y aller parce qu'en fait si je
comprends bien vous dites que en gros la
moitié des internes ont un retard de
formation ou ne sont pas formés à la
prise en charge de patients qu'ovide
vous parler évidemment des problèmes
psychologiques de d'un grand nombre d'un
terne
vous imaginez ce que ça veut dire
d'entendre ça pour les éventuels
patients parce qu'ils se disent eh ben
c'est pas c'est pas gagné 1 c'est pas
gagner j'espère que je vais rester en
bonne santé
moi je dois dire j'ai un peu de mal un
peu de mal parce que on a fait venir ici
sous serment sous serment des ministres
des directeurs généraux de la santé des
responsables ars des tous les oiseaux
ils nous ont tous dit alors vous
n'imaginez pas ce qu'on a appris depuis
mars
vous n'imaginez pas combien on a
actualisé les relations fait en sorte
qu'ils aient plus de fluidité faire en
sorte que l'hôpital répondent mieux
faire en sorte que les blocages
administratifs réglementaires soient
levés
parce que on sait bien que l'épidémie
est là n'est pas terminée et puis quand
on vous entend on a plutôt tendance à se
dire en fait
les blocages sont pas levées les
relations inter hôpitaux sont pas
meilleurs qui a sept ou huit mois la
formation des personnels à l'hôpital
n'est pas meilleur qui a sept huit mois
sur la prise en charge qu'ovide tu es un
peu tenté de dire bon je moi je
comprends très bien que le c ur n'est
pas donné satisfaction sur un certain
nombre de sujets mais si on voulait sur
vous voulez de respirer quelques
éléments un peu comment dire optimistes
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment qu'au
moins sur certains sujets
la prise en charge l'organisation le la
capacité hospitalier a évolué en huit ou
neuf mois ou est ce que vous nous dites
aujourd'hui nous praticiens direct dans
les hôpitaux
nous vous disons tranquillement que mi
octobre 2020 on n'est pas mieux équipés
pas mieux formés pas plus s'équiper pas
plus fort mais que nous l'étions au mois
de mars
en clair courage
oui attention votre réponse ne voyez pas
notre collègue je suis au suicide ce
serait dommage on regretterait alesi
répond b 6e
je crois que je crois que vous je vais
répondre à cette recherche d'optimisme
mais mais mais d'abord je crois que vous
soulevez un point qui qui est important
c'est si les questions des
interlocuteurs ce qu'on s'est rendu
compte pendant cette crise c'est qu'en
fait on avait l'expérience de h1n1 et
pendant 1 h aréna
les syndicats professionnels avaient été
beaucoup consulté notamment les
syndicats d'internés étant donné que ces
internes qui avait fait beaucoup de
vaccination ce qu'on s'est rendu compte
dans cette crise c'est que déjà on
n'était plus un interlocuteur des
gestions de crise sanitaire et qu'en
plus les interlocuteurs qui désormais
été choisis étaient les fédérations
hospitalières
fédérer fhf et fhp moi j'ai rien contre
les comptes les fédérations tout au
contraire
mais le dialogue avec les avec les
professionnels et leurs représentants
c'est quelque chose d'inestimable si on
veut connaître les réalités du terrain
on ne peut pas faire sans or force est
de constater que cette modification des
interlocuteurs aujourd'hui elle continue
quand on voit que le comité de suivi du
ségur ne sont invités aux réunions de
suivi que les représentants signataires
des accords ça veut dire qu'il ya la
moitié des représentants du personnel
qui sont évincés des discussions et ça
c'est gravissime parce que c'est pas
parce que la cgt ou jeune médecin ou
actions praticiens hospitaliers n'ont
pas signé les accords que ils ont pas
quand même une valeur à apporter dont
justement cette transformation du
système de santé et sa chute à je trouve
ça très grave
après si on doit chercher de l'optimisme
oui moi je vois des choses très
positives
mais mais ces choses positives elles
sont elles sont surtout dans dans le
retournement de notre société c'est à
dire qu'enfin la santé est devenue un
sujet prioritaire à la fois dans les
médias et aussi dans les politiques
publiques
quand on est invité ici c'est un signe
positif parce qu'on peut parler aussi
nos conditions de travail
chose qui à une époque aurait été aurait
été plus difficile en tout cas ce
n'était pas un sujet qui était sous le
feu des projecteurs et nous ça nous a ça
nous a aidé pour dénoncer les conditions
de travail
et puis que la société civile se
prennent en main ces questions
maintenant il faut arriver à transformer
l'essai quand quand on voit que ya eu un
projet de loi de la sécurité sociale
avec un monde dames qui nous envoient
encore vers des restrictions budgétaires
eh ben ça veut dire qu'on va encore
fermé des lits voilà on en a fermé mais
bien fermé près de 2000 en 2019 tendent
en 2019 oui mais voilà on prévoit en
2021 enfermé encore on prévoit de faire
encore des économies
je veux dire quand on regarde les
conditions de travail il n'ya pas que
les questions liées à la crise sanitaire
c'est les conditions de travail étaient
très mauvaises
rien que sur l'hôtellerie par exemple
sur la qualité des chambres de garde
je veux dire on nous demande de dormir
dans des endroits qui sont insalubres
avec des fenêtres qui ne ferment pas et
pas de draps on paye des repas on nous
sert un bol de riz du morceau de pain et
art nature
il faut comprendre que ça les personnels
hospitaliers y partent on a beau lever
tous les blocages et ses tanks ont fait
un peu attention à nos personnels et
qu'on fait pas attention à l'égard des
notamment sur sur les sur les manières
de les accueillir mais les gens vont
partir
voilà là il ya un tiers des postes de
praticiens hospitaliers qui sont vacants
donc beaucoup d'infirmiers il ya
beaucoup de lit qui sont fermées par
manque de personnel et là effectivement
on a besoin d'un choc d'autres activités
on n'arrête pas de l'appeler mais on a
besoin de le voir
et puis et puis on a besoin de faire
revenir des personnels sinon non ça va
pas s'améliorer donc l'optimisme c'est
que
man vous et la société prennent en
charge ces mesures et fasse en sorte
qu'ils aient à nouveau les moyens
nécessaires pour faire fonctionner
correctement le système de santé pour
pour compléter un peu moi j'ai
l'impression également que ce qui est
positif dans cette crise et que les
professionnels de santé sont plaints de
résilience et c'est que quelque part
dans ce chaos qui a été la crise
sanitaire
il ya aussi un sens c'est qu'en fait la
santé publique et la santé de la
population c'est aussi le coeur de notre
métier c'est pour ça qu'on est là
par contre on nous donne pas les moyens
de le faire et ça part et ça comme tu le
disais il ya vraiment ce sentiment
mélangé de colère et de peur quand on va
à l'hôpital tous lés jours maintenant
j'ai pas l'impression que par contre
vraiment dans le même sens que la
gestion rh à l'hôpital n'ait changé
vraiment l'hôpital pour moi il retenu le
même qu'avant la crise qu'ovide les
gestion rh sont exactement les mêmes
on a exactement le même niveau de lits
fermés par manque de personnel dans les
hôpitaux
ce dont je continue de m'étonner
actuellement ce qui m'étonnait déjà
pendant la première vague c'est que il
ya quelqu'un qui a un pouvoir de
réquisition des professionnels de santé
et il n'a toujours pas été utilisé les
hôpitaux manquent de professionnels les
préfets ont la possibilité de
réquisitionner des professionnels de
santé ça n'a pas été fait et ça n'est
pas encore fait pourtant il ya des
grilles de rémunérations qui sont
prévues pour les personnes de santé
réquisitionnés
ça n'est toujours pas fait donc moi
qu'est ce que je dis à mes interne qui
veulent pas retourner à l'hôpital et d
une deuxième fois pour ne pas être payés
pendant trois mois et qu'à côté de ça il
ya un décret spécifique qui écrit noir
sur blanc ce qui doivent être payés
pendant une réquisition et qui les
payent beaucoup mieux que le smic
horaire pendant une ornière de 12 ou 24
heures qu'est ce que je leur dis merci
bien bréville merci monsieur le
président merci pour votre présentation
qui s'était délitée j'avoue je suis très
ému en fait parce que je salue en je
salue en vous l'engagement de la
jeunesse et je voudrais vous faire
préciser deux trois petites choses que
je crois avoir compris donc bon très
généralement on voit bien qu'il y avait
eu un manque d'organisation totale dans
la gestion de cette crise est-ce que
j'ai bien compris que vous avez pris les
devants pour vous organiser et que
personne en fait nous vous avez
sollicité pour cela
est ce que c'est bien ça ensuite est-ce
que vous avez eu l'impression que vous
aviez devancé ou que ça allait venir
éventuellement cette organisation ou pas
ensuite vous avez bien mentionné que
c'est vous qui savez le mieux qu'elle
interne est capable de faire ceci ou
cela et que donc dans une dans un avenir
si on devait organiser davantage la la
gestion d'une crise
vous pourriez être à même de d'être
à la manoeuvre en fait pour faire ce que
vous avez fait d'ailleurs de vous même
et moi je voulais aussi vous demander
sur la formation donc vous dites que une
grande faim 46% ont eu le sentiment de
ne pas avoir été formés est ce qu'il
faudrait l'inscrire dorénavant dans les
formations et puis dernière chose vous
avez dit que vous n'aviez pas pu suivre
tout votre cursus habituel et mais
malgré tout vous avez vous avez agi
pendant la crise
et est-ce que ça ça ne pourrait pas
faire l'objet d'une espèce de
valorisation dans l'obtention de vos
diplômes parce que vous avez quand même
dû et puis on voit avec quelle énergie
vous avez fait ça donc valoriser cette
chose-là et et permettre que ça que ça
rentre en compte et que ça puisse faire
en sorte que vous puissiez obtenir vos
diplômes plus facilement
voilà je vous remercie merci merci pour
ces questions et fait effectivement
effectivement c'est s'est mobilisée à
notre propre initiative pour vous dire
on a fait une assemblée générale qui est
qui a regroupé près de 80 personnes de
métier de manière dématérialisée là bien
sûr dans toute la france et devant
l'absence de consignes on a décidé de
s'organiser nous-mêmes et effectivement
on pense que c'est que c'est ce qui
fonctionne le mieux
ce conte ce qu'on déplore c'est que
derrière l'administration a eu un
certain un délai pour pour se mettre en
place et que souvent ça a été un frein
et et que ce qui nous a au final donner
le plus de travail ça à pas et étant
d'identifier les services où il y avait
besoin de renfort est de trouver des
volontaires et de déplacer des personnes
parce qu'en pratique énormément en
interne se sont portés volontaires ce
qui a été le plus difficile ça a été de
les faire payer
ça constitue en quelque sorte sa
l'aspect optimiste de la chose c'est que
vous avez été très réactifs et que vous
avez su organiser
et quelque chose qui n'était pas prévu
par les autorités ah oui là la
mobilisation des internes elle l a été
incroyable c'est vraiment on a lancé des
questionnaires et on avait près de 90%
des internes qui avaient répondu et qui
sont et qui sont recensés qui ont mis
leurs compétences et qui étaient
volontaires pour pour se mobiliser
julien disait attendre les réquisitions
on voulait pas attendre les réquisitions
parce qu'on voulait pas attendre que ce
soit un préfet une administration qui
connaît pas les réalités de terrain qui
nous met au mauvais endroit au mauvais
moment
mais c'est sur que derrière quand on se
retrouve avec des internes qui sont pas
payer ses fins ça peut ça paraît encore
en ré semblables excusez-moi j'ai oublié
les autres questions est rien la
valorisation de l'expérience
en fait nos diplômes nos diplômes on
finira par les avoir en fait pour être
pour être interne faut faire faut faire
sur tous ces stages pratiques
on ferait on fera en sorte de on fera en
sorte de rattraper nos stages ils seront
quand même validé le problème c'est la
qualité de ses dribbles de ses diplômés
de la formation qu'on a obtenu dire
quand on se passe de trois mois de
formation on se passe de trois mois de
formation si on veut les récupérer il
faut refaire trois mois de formation
derrière
donc si c'est un temps perdu qu'on
récupérera pas et on
j'ai beau réfléchir et tourner le
question dans tous les sens à moins de
faire trois mois de formation plus afin
de l'internât et pai apparent de façon
de valoriser ça après ce sera valorisé
parce que il y en a beaucoup qui ont
appris dans à faire affaire de
l'organisationnel et de l'est de la
santé publique et ça c'est clairement
c'est nécessaire et il ya un grand
déficit en france sur la formation de
tous les médecins la santé publique
parce que d'accord on a une spécialité
de santé publique avec des médecins qui
ne font que de la santé publique
néanmoins nous ce qu'on dit c'est que
tous les médecins devraient car des
compétences en santé publique et pas
qu'eux aussi en gestion de projet en
communication en gestion de personnel et
pour ça ce qu'on aurait besoin c'est que
les facultés de médecine elle s'ouvre
sur l'université
ce qui est actuellement pas le cas parce
que actuellement les facultés de
médecine sont enclavés ce ne sont que
des médecins qui y forment d'autres
médecins pour ce qui est de 6 on a
devancé en fait la réponse des
administrations
face à cette crise sanitaire en ce qui
concerne l'île de france on a vraiment
travaillé main dans la main avec la
grèce ile de france alors oui peut-être
que parce que on était au courant de la
situation par nos collègues en géo en
région grand est
on est arrivé avec une solution clé en
main auprès de la grèce ile de france en
leur disant bon voilà nous ce qu'on veut
faire c'est ça il va falloir que tout le
monde se mettre d'accord pour qu'on
puisse proposer des réaffectations
d'inter dans l'île de france avec la
corde
ces directeurs de formation et des
doyens et ils nous ont dit banco en fait
parce que effectivement je pense que il
n'allait pas avoir les données et les
réponses que que nous que nous avions
parce que on est on croule déjà sous les
sollicitations d'un terne qui parce
qu'ils étaient passés dans un service
particulier qui il savait avait besoin
des aides ont pu les rejoindre mais il y
avait des internes
tous les jours toutes les deux minutes
on avait un nouveau message qui nous est
où est ce que je veux ou est-ce que je
vais et on avait besoin de répondre à
ces internats qui en fait que la rs ou
que les facultés de médecine en fait ont
beaucoup de mal à approcher autrement et
si on était capable de refaire la même
chose là actuellement je suis pas sûr
parce que c'était vraiment une
conjonction très spécial c'est que on
avait beaucoup d'internautes qui étaient
en situation de grossesse qui ont pu
nous aider dans la gestion vraiment
administrative delà des flux et on avait
également beaucoup d'internautes qui
étaient en recherche et en fait
du coup qui étaient dans des
laboratoires qui ont fermé sauf que là
en fait c'est la période de l'année
actuellement où les internes ne sont pas
en laboratoire ils sont en enseignements
donc je ne sais pas avec les internes je
pourrais faire ça c'est bon bien on va
vous remercier messieurs il ya plus de
questions
madame de roche peut-être vous avez pas
tellement parler de la situation
actuelle le regard sur sur les mesures
prises actuellement
parce que ce qu'on ressent c'est
maintenant que l'épidémie est et sur
tout le territoire avec des degrés -
bien sûr mais surtout le territoire
alors qu'avant on est passé d'une phase
d'un grand test pour arriver à la phase
ile-de-france et de régions ailleurs
plutôt épargné comment ça se passe
maintenant est ce que est ce que dans
les services
vos collègues vous disent nous on est en
tension en effet il faut pas que ça
augmente trop parce qu'on n'a pas de
réserve pour faire venir quelqu'un
comment ça marche parce que oui ce qui
est difficile à faire comprendre c'est
des mesures très restrictive qui sont
présents je ne juge pas mais alors que
si on regarde objectivement c'est 1500
personnes l'animation sur tout le
territoire et donc comment vous
expliquer sa salle la situation actuelle
comment vous la voyez vous ce qui ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est quand on parle de quand on parle
de passion qu'ovide en réanimation
c'est en plus des autres patients or les
services de réanimation en temps normal
ils sont déjà ils sont déjà remplies
donc là c'est des patients qui arrivent
en plus la situation
ça m'importe c'est pour ça que j'ai
insisté sur le contexte et que la
situation dans lequel est arrivée la
crise qu vide pour les hôpitaux elle
était déjà était déjà extrêmement tendue
en terme de manque de moyens de
personnel et de saturation débit donc là
on est dans une situation où très
clairement les capacités elles sont
largement dépassées et en plus on a
quand même tous peur parce que on sait
qu'il ya la grippe saisonnière qui qui
va arriver
donc non là dessus là dessus on trouve
que toutes les mesures sanitaires qui
peuvent être pris pour limiter la
propagation du virus elles sont bonnes
est ce qu'il faut bien voir aussi c'est
que en plus deux ans plus deux des
vagues d'épidémie là ce qui se passe
c'est qu'il ya la fatigue des personnels
et la fatigue et enfin la fatigue des
personnels ses mains de ces maintenant
qu avec l arrivée ils n'ont pas pu
prendre de congés cet été ils ont dû
mobilisés bah inéluctablement on aura
plus on aura plus de réserve comme on a
pu avoir lors de la première vague
surtout que là aussi c'est un moment en
ce qui concerne des internes c'est un
moment particulier là on est le 15
octobre dans quinze jours il ya eu dix
mille nouveaux internes qui arrive en
est qui arrive sur la france entière
il y en a huit mille qui partent qu'ils
sont diplômés donc sur le territoire il
va y avoir huit mille nouveaux médecins
diplômés et va y avoir huit mille
nouveaux médecins qui seront en
formation qui vont apprendre leur
spécialité ce qu'on sait déjà où en tout
cas localement c'est de toute façon le
plan blanc et déjà réactive en
ile-de-france donc les congés des
professionnels sont annulés fortement
conseillé d'annuler ces conflits moi
j'ai plein de situations internes qui en
fait du coup n'ont pas pris de congé
depuis un an parce que n'ont pas pu en
prendre pendant la première crise n'ont
pas pu reprendre cet été parce que
habituellement les internes sont là pour
tenir le service l'été pendant que les
médecins à diplôme et sans vacances et
nous on prend nos vacances en septembre
octobre et la deuxième vague
et oui c'est ça aussi c'est que là il ya
déjà le ras-le-bol se faisait pressentir
précédemment parce que comme tu l'a
rappelé justin on a eu un mouvement de
grève avant avant la crise sanitaire qui
appelait à plus de moyens pour l'hôpital
public qui est notre outil de formation
mais là en fait on s'est bien rendu
compte en fait plus que des limites de
la gestion hospitalière de la limite de
la limite de la gestion de la santé en
france
on s'est rendu compte qu'en fait il y
avait un problème systémique que même
s'il y avait une crise sanitaire et que
tout le monde a été plein de bonne
volonté et ben en fait j'ai fait plein
de choses qui bloquait pas de partout
que ce soit administrative que ce soit
financier là les internes je pense que
ils leurs espoirs et leur volonté de
pour la volonté de directement aller au
front
si une deuxième vague là c'est un peu
entachée oui ils iront mais je ne sais
pas comment peut il annonce que ce qui
est sûr c'est que les intervenants
continuent et vont continuer à se
mobiliser au maximum de leurs capacités
c'est sur leur capacité que que j'ai
plus de doute et il va quand même
enfin les premiers jours de novembre
vont quand même être une période
particulière dans les hôpitaux français
je suis comme lady julien il ya 8000
nouveaux internes qui arrive qui ont
jamais eu ses fonctions de prescripteurs
et qui encore aujourd'hui c'est
malheureux de le dire mais se retrouve
du jour au lendemain en charge de
patients est quasiment quasiment
seulement les services donc c'est
toujours une période particulier le mois
de novembre
et là en plus avec avec la période cosy
de sap est le moment de se faire
hospitaliser
et merci mais d'autant plus et d'autre
est d'autant plus lors de la crise
sanitaire les hospitalisations qu'ovide
on arrivait à les restreindre c'était il
y avait des services qu vides il y avait
des réanimations qu'ovide la maintenant
en fait le coville il touche toutes les
toute la population donc il va falloir
en fait avoir des lits de gériatrie de
covile il va falloir avoir des seins des
valeurs à avoir de la médecine en terme
d'éco vide
enfin l'ensemble de l'organisation
hospitalière va devoir se réorganiser
avec eux avec toute la population qui
manque qui peut maintenant être
infectées et sauf qu'en fait c'est lilas
de typiquement de gériatrie qui est un
service très important pour l'hôpital
parce que ça c'est des services d'aval
particulièrement des urgences c'est
particulièrement celles qui sont fermées
par manque de personnel
et et moi je suis interne de psychiatrie
donc je prêche aussi pour ma paroisse
mais pour la psychiatrie ça a été
d'autant plus désastreux là les la suite
de la première vague ont été
catastrophiques dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques on ice dans les services
de psychiatrie on a eu énormément de
demandes de soins pour plein de
problématiques de santé différentes mais
des hôpitaux psychiatriques en france
ils sont dans une situation autant voire
bien plus compliquée que les hôpitaux
généraux et là par exemple moi pour le
terrain en ile de france il ya des
services et des hôpitaux qui n'ont plus
du tout un lit depuis plusieurs mois dès
qu'on fait sortir quelqu'un on a déjà
dix personnes qui attendent je me
permets d'insister sûr sûr sûr ce qu'a
dit julien parce que c'est vrai que dans
notamment dans les médias il ya un biais
qu'on entend c'est que on ne parle que
de réanimation et de lits de réanimation
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
les patients avant d'être en réanimation
ils sont hospitalisées dans des services
de médecine que dans ses services de
médecine il ya particulièrement pas de
moyens et quand la nuit il ya une
infirmière qui va gérer 28 patients vous
avez une urgence les 27 autres sont des
auto entrepreneurs
c'est ça il faut il faut arriver à bien
le comprendre et ne pas se focaliser
uniquement sur la question de la
réanimation les besoins ils sont
particuliers quand même en médecine en
service de médecine
là dessus il faut il va falloir
augmenter les moyens et surtout les
moyens des paramédicaux aussi c'est un
message que je peux faire passer c'est
que ok il ya un manque de médecins il
manque un tiers des postes de ph
les internes ils sont là ils resteront
là les effectifs sont stables
là où il ya vraiment des manqué et une
fuite de personnel c'est
particulièrement chez les infirmiers et
aides soignants qui vivent des
conditions de travail qui sont qu'ils
sont
qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont terribles
merci messieurs quelques petites
observations en ce qui me concerne pour
essayer de rassurer nos collègues j'ai
là le rapport d'étape de la mission
indépendante qui avait été nommé par le
président de la république
pour ce qui est des excès de mortalité
en france
l'excès de mentalité en france est de 28
mille trois cent six c'est vrai qu'il
est en allemagne de 7552 seulement mais
par ailleurs il est de 47 1484 en italie
46 1742 en espagne 5197 en suède
proportionnellement à la population
c'est beaucoup plus qu'en france 57 1844
au royaume uni et 190 mine aux états
unis il ya par là que la situation de la
france n'est certainement pas bonne mais
elle n'est pas catastrophique
le deuxième point qui me semble
important dans ce que vous aviez je vous
rejoins complètement sur les hôpitaux
psychiatriques les hôpitaux psychiatrie
c'est un problème de financement
ils sont actuellement financier sous
forme de dotation annuelle est la
meilleure solution serait certainement
de trouver un autre type de financement
peut-être pas l'activité à un t2 est
incomplète parce que ça posera un
problème majeur mais un mélange des deux
serait pas inutile et enfin je voudrais
revenir sur ce que vous avez dit vous
monsieur le président si on le
financement de sécurité sociale
je suis complètement d'accord avec vous
il faut donner à l'ensemble des
personnels soignants de ce pays
les moyens de travailler mais pour cela
il faut et que le gouvernement et que le
parlement
l'ensemble du parlement accepte le
principe d'un ondam au moins quatre
c'est à dire donc donné chaque année aux
soignants à la santé française 8
milliards de plus mais pas huit
milliards de plus en 2021
et puis ensuite on court les 8 milliards
de plus chaque année
il faudra trouver l'argent sur ce
merci à vous et bonne journée en mai
alors laurence ta solution et je les
accepte à condition qu'ils acceptent la
mienne aussi
la solution j accepte à condition qu'ils
acceptent la mienne également on en
parle
y'a pas de soucis merci à tous merci
beaucoup
voilà pour cette audition des syndicats
d'un terne des hôpitaux des syndicats
qui étaient donc entendue par la
commission d' enquête consacrée à la
gestion de l'épidémie de coronavirus on
passe à une autre audition à présent
florence parly a été entendu par la
commission des affaires étrangères
une
[Musique]